dear J and Gil we hope you guys are
having a blast on your vacation
you're probably surfing down the Amazon
River you know to go rafting on a jungle
river find a lost civilization oh maybe
a penguin it's winking from branch to
branch in total Tarzan fashion and
eating buzzy rocks aka
coconuts you guys really do seem like
the best of pals the J we need to know
what happened between you and Lonnie you
guys grew super close by the end of
descendants two but now you've committed
to a year-long vacation and Lonnie is
nowhere to be found
we want some answers J we're in auradon
could Lonnie have gone we can't believe
she wasn't in descendants three
but according to Diane Doan the actress
who plays her Lonnie had her reasons for
keeping away keep watching to get all
the deets we definitely weren't the only
ones who noticed that Lonnie was a
no-show in descendant 3 this strikes us
as strange especially since Lonnie was
such a vital character in both
descendants 1 & 2 Lonnie is brave smart
and unpredictable which would have made
her a total asset plus she knows how to
wield a sword like there's no tomorrow
so she would have been a valued Ally
during the fight with the metal nights
while Lonnie has her reasons for keeping
away it makes no sense that she would
miss her best friend Jane's birthday
party and since she's such a good
fighter the Lonnie we all know and love
totally would have offered her services
once she found out about the sleep spell
but most peculiar of all is how Jade
didn't even mention Lonnie once
throughout the film we got the
impression that Jay and Lonnie were
couple goals at the end of descendants
to Jay supported her and helped her
become the captain of the swords and
shields team whereas Lonnie saw Jay for
who he truly was and risked your life to
help the VK save Ben this V ka K
relationship was a dream come true which
is why tons of fans have shipped Johnny
since the very beginning we were certain
that these two would be dating by the
time to send in three rolled around but
no Lonnie was nowhere to be found and
Jay didn't feel the need to mention her
at all it's possible that Jay and Lonnie
gave romance
try but quickly realized that they were
better off as friends this would explain
why Lonnie wasn't present and why Jay
chose to keep quiet about the whole
ordeal another thing worth mentioning is
that descendants 3 takes place in the
summertime the vks revealed that Audrey
was staying at auradon prep for the
summer because of summer school theory
hook thought this was hilarious and
blamed summer school for Audrey's
villainous rampage but we all know that
that's not the case if Lonnie wasn't at
auradon prep that means she didn't want
to take summer classes and probably
remained in her hometown of Northern Wei
but according to Diane Lonnie had no
choice but to be written out of the
script and will reveal why in just a few
moments the real reason why Lonnie
wasn't in descendents 3 is stated on her
descendents fandom page here we find out
that Lonnie is absent due to touring the
United States of auradon with her roar
team knowing this it makes perfect sense
that Lonnie wasn't at Jane's birthday
party or involved in descendants 3
whatsoever but part of us still wishes
that Jay would have talked about Lonnie
at some point in the film we were really
rooting for this couple another reason
why Lonnie wasn't in d3 has everything
to do with the storyline name characters
like jay carlos and doug didn't have the
most lines throughout the film so adding
Lonnie to the equation would have
complicated things in the end the script
for d3 was designed to follow mal Edie
Emma and Audrey's stories which sort of
put other characters on the backburner
so at first we thought that Lonnie was
purposely written out of the d3 script
and complicate things but that's not
exactly true in the end the real reason
Lonnie wasn't in descendents 3 has
everything to do with the actress who
portrays her Diane is a 28 year old
actress who started acting back in 2009
she played in a handful of short movies
before being cast as Lonnie in 2014 for
the next three years Diane would voice
her character and Disney descendants
school of secrets and descendant wicked
world and she would also appear in d1
and d2 but by the time Diane wrapped up
filming for descendants 2 she realized
that she wanted to expand
her horizons so she started auditioning
for different roles so when it came time
to film descendants three diana has some
conflict issues that she could not
ignore as a result the actress was
unable to reprise her role as Lani which
led her to being written out of the
script what we do love the Jay and
Lonnie ship we couldn't help but fall in
love with Jay and gills budding
friendship throughout the three quill
always are you get a kick out of a fairy
[ __ ] I like the way that you can bounce
around and jump up things Jango might
not have bonded if Lani had been around
so in the end we're pretty happy with
how things worked out
if Lani had been present in the film the
writers might have made Jay and Lani an
item which could have prevented Jay from
going on a year-long voyage with Gil you
know it will be fun to go rafting on a
jungle River find a lost civilization or
maybe a penguin let's put it to a vote
to find out who the most popular couple
is comment jay and lani or jay and gil
in the comments section below
and that's a wrap is that subscribe
button and don't forget to give this
video a big thumbs up thanks for
watching we'll see you soon
[Music]